of a desert highway in the small town of
Tonopah Nevada there is a motel it's the
coulrophobia ultimate nightmare and 30
to 45 bucks a night with three and a
half stars on Yelp and TripAdvisor the
motel is actually a pretty good deal it
comes with a 1970s microwave in each
room HBO is included and Bob the
proprietor is said to be incredibly
hospitable but the hotel has a theme
that doesn't sit right with every guest
Bob runs the clown from the moment a
guest checks into the clown motel they
are greeted by a life-sized clown figure
holding two smaller clowns like little
evil pets the walls are covered in clown
posters clown toys clown dolls there are
over 600 clowns in the office and the
clown theme is ubiquitous recently the
clown Motel has rocketed to fame powered
in part by the ever-increasing sense of
coulrophobia
it's my guess that if you were born in
the 1980s or after when you think of
clowns you think of evil but why the
roots of this go all the way back to a
guy named Joseph Grimaldi who created
both the makeup and much of the humor
style we associate with modern clowns he
was beloved and incredibly famous but he
also had a tragic personal life and when
his memoirs were written by Charles
Dickens
Dickens created the image of the tragic
clown the clown who is hiding a deep
sadness under that makeup and those
smiles this tragic clown character would
be what we associated with clowns for
many years to come in the 1930s we had a
whole wave of hobo clowns but in the 50s
and 60s clowns started to become cleaned
up they were drunks they were funny they
were for children
this was the ronald mcdonald clown and
then came the quintessential moment when
clowns turned evil in the 1970s John
Wayne Gacy killed 33
people he became known as the killer
clown from he'll on out it is nothing
but evil clowns you have Stephen King's
it you have killer clowns from outer
space and as there are less good clowns
and children see more and more evil
clowns it creates a feedback loop in
which the clown has basically become
synonymous with terror so well the clown
motel may feel like something dreamed up
in a horror writers fevered imagination
in fact the clown motel says we just
like clowns it's kind of our fault
you're afraid of course not everyone is
afraid of clowns so you can always walk
next door to the hundred year old miner
cemetery they'd also love a visit
subscribe here and watch more videos
here what is it like to actually stay
there
Christopher Sabella a comic writer and
journalist launched a Kickstarter to go
live in the clown motel for a full month
which he is doing at this moment so I
had to ask is it terrifying what's it
like there I thought love didn't just a
theme for a motel it's literally and all
the better like 200 miles from from
civilization either direction no
everyday sort of a new adventure really
what's going to happen did I believe I
have to plant portraits on my wall that
are staring at me right now like
basically totally wrong now if anything
I'm just getting more I think I'm only
going to be more comfortable with clams
in I've ever been